hello and welcome to this video mrs.
courage of round seven of the candidates
tournament currently held in Moscow we
get this round seven was played
yesterday and I'm now getting around to
to cover that we have four games as
usual and we're going to start with them
game geary island in a situation where
giri is on 50% he has played six draws
and Ireland in the current situations
are plus one so he's rather comfortable
I guess with his position still very
much in contention so Geary should try
something he goes for a default play and
we get a Queens gambit declined with not
bt7 yeah this move has gained some
momentum recently one ideas that we seen
that in the event early all survived the
bhavishya thing against huronian when
ideas that the nowadays popular Bishop
f4 setups against Bishop e7 this is the
main move nowadays can be answered with
the capture and this led to interesting
play in the mentioned Aronian are not
game
give me however goes with Quincy to this
is the rare move but an interesting move
black now has to decide what to do he
can invite various trans positions at
that point for example black could play
Bishop e7 now just normal-looking move
after which white for example could go
for some cards but structure the Queens
gambit declined exchange structure many
things possible and that goes for an
active possibility he goes Bishop before
so mixing Queens gambit and nimzo-indian
theme cm in three by Gary Jack to cons
III and played Castle so this is a
position that easily could have come
from a Queen c2 names oh yeah it would
completely mainline theoretical position
without those tools inserted it makes a
difference but the themes are very
similar Bishop g5 age six and now
honored goes with c5 yeah this is an
interesting move he tries to actually
open up the position even though Giri
has got the bishop pair why because he's
better developed black has castled
already he wants to make his development
advantage count we've discussed
something already in the event I think
that was during the game sweedler
Aronian we're also Iranian went for an
opening of the position early on even
though the opponent had the bishop hair
yeah so c5 opens up the position here he
goes
III trying to develop his Bishop on f1
and now Alan takes on d4 yeah so what
should Y do now if white recaptures with
the pawn then he probably will play in
iqp position after a further capture on
c4 black can take immediately or I can
play b6 we can look at the capture if we
started that and now black goes maybe b6
or a six is also move the ideas to play
quick Bishop e7 rook c8 yeah note how
good blacks development is he's very
quick and his pieces are all came yeah
they're all fulfil a useful role Geary
plays differently it takes with the
Queen this is probably the more ya
logical way it does not hamper the pawn
structure at all
rook e8 played by Anand and now we come
to the key position of this game very
early on I absolutely cannot figure out
what give me did next I think he said
afterwards that he feared that after C
txt 585 on
have some interesting preparation going
on but well that's all nice and good but
you're not going to qualify for a world
championship match with 14 draws so if
you have white against someone who's on
+1 and they have given you the bishop
pair to play with you should somehow
continue this game I mean the thing is
what he did is he took on f6 and after
that it this is so utterly unambitious
he can you might as well make a draw
right away yeah so why not take five and
now some move I mean it really doesn't
matter where and you just have to
continue him even if y'all won't go all
the way back to the one I really don't
see why this should be a draw like
Johnny five maybe 22 and 12 this is a
position that white can certainly play
I'm not claiming he's a lot better or
anything but I mean you have to win
games at one point so by just trading
off here like this and play this
position you're not going to qualify for
any World Championship match yeah so
okay we basically can I get the rest
this is so equal that it doesn't need a
2,780 play like honor to make the draw
but yeah it's very easy to make a draw
it was black you just plain normal stuff
and get the draw so really very
unofficial to take on f6 and a bit
mysterious because I had that totally
understand being yeah paying some
respect to the opponent's preparation if
you are in a somewhat sharp position
this can be a wise decision sometimes to
just kind of yeah dodge the dodge you
challenge and say ok and you probably
have something install that maybe let's
be a little bit conservative that's all
good and probably good tournament
strategy but what what exactly is the
big danger yeah yeah anyway let's go to
the next game what's the next game too
cover the orders actually kind of
interesting to check I think I'll go
with kayaking Aronian our to kill
leaders going at okay kayaking 93 and g3
yeah this is some here sign that he does
not want to play a long a 45 theoretical
line we get this him Aronian is very
much sticking to the set up against the
Kings Indian attack on the Kings
fianchetto
the white side he plays this very
classical setup d5 Knight f6 six Bishop
e7 basically anticipating that white
goes form some kind of Catalan for
example like d4 castles oops
c4 takes and we're in the main line
Catalan by transposition this is
something that most players probably now
would go for can yeah keno ever has a
different idea place the move d3 castles
and Knight bTW to just playing Kings
Indian attack style angling for the
movie for interesting choice this is not
an opening that is supposed to give
white a theoretical advantage but what
opening actually does where black is not
doing something stupid so essentially it
means white is going for yeah again with
all the pieces on the board probably yes
something that could heat up a little
bit later so a five by Aronian
surprising and very rare move but not a
bad move he's known for being original
or an original player and in this
position Aronian has not gone for the
mains and the past which is C 5 C 5 is
the main booth and E for not seasick
five this kind of thing in fact what he
has played mostly is Knight to c6 which
is a it's a bit strange looking but it
has it has a point after white cone Eve
form Aronian played this a couple of
times and then a five and whether there
is some logic to that IAM I mean we have
a completely symmetrical central poor
information there with e4 and e5 and the
defund open but White has a bishop on g2
which is probably not so great but on
the other hand the knight on c6 is also
not ideally placed still it's hard to
believe that black should be in any big
danger here this is this for example was
played in a game between the two players
kayaking and Aronian in Zurich last year
but now a five gem
that's a weird-looking move it gains
space on the Queen side before a four
yeah it gains space on the Queen side
and quite often actually fits into
Black's general plan for example now
after a three is played back aki-nee was
probably a little bit afraid that a
three would happen so a 3 makes probably
sense yeah here um white probably most
obvious looking movies the movie 5 after
a 597 not to have one we get a very
typical position from the skins in
Unitec setup
p5 we should afford this kind of thing
or maybe age for first and this is a
transposition to a mainline that usually
starts with black in this position going
c5 and only a5 later
I'm very sharp position with chances for
both sides white has got this ideas like
Bishop f4 Knight comes up
g5 queen h5 playing on the kingside
while Black has made already huge
progress on the queenside
very sharp stuff in the game age 4th
played by kayaking this is some probably
not a great decision because the center
is not yet closed not yet to clarify the
central position and aronia reacts
availeth and he takes on you form after
D takes before he can go if v or b5 both
them seem very much playable that could
also lead to sharply after E 5 for
example this is a very even yeah very
tense interesting position might might
even have ideas like that I think that D
takes was a little bit more in the
spirit of the position ki can took with
the night and now I decided to take with
the rook yeah I'm not a huge fan of that
decision because the main idea it seems
was to you have options like that but
they never really materialized we will
see when b5 happens and now Knight g5
and I don't think that this is a
particularly successful idea that was
quite clearly the idea of age 4 but we
see that after Luke a6 covering the
night and getting out of that sensitive
diagonal Queen age 5 a black just goes
age 6 and this is not leading to much
black is not really trying to take on g5
technically I mean if I place some move
and c3 for example then taking is not
really on there
as Luke h4 is a dead limb
threat him but still it's hard to
believe that white can keep the night
down forever
yeah if black plays a normal move let's
say Bishop to d7 this is all not yea
very successful I mean white can try
stuff like that but there is 95 and
again that should be lead to much now he
decided to retreat right away it's
probably the right decision yeah and now
we come to the problem f5 is the thing
the route gets attacked it cannot go to
g4 it essentially has to go back yet
here Aronian I think missed the chance
and he also stated that in the press
conference himself so I'm basically just
copying what he said Bishop f6 now was a
good move the point is to take control
over the e5 square and this is very
important black has more space here and
some ideas to improve a very direct idea
would be Bishop 278 winning the Queen
okay white will probably move the knight
but it doesn't really look like a good
position for white him also this is
probably necessary to ever move the c1
bishop yeah instead he played Bishop to
d7 and now kayaking displays his
defensive qualities he goes 95 that's a
good move white has less space wants to
trade the typical procedure and gathers
this is what happened the worse now is
definitely over for white rupee 1 is a
good move allowing the bishop to move
this was what Aronian had expected in a
way to happen and then after before he
has a good position
Group B one is stronger it is not a
weaken the queenside at all and ya know
it's difficult for black to make any
headway he decided to play in the most
direct way with f4 but this didn't lead
to much straights and the Queen took on
c5 keeping an eye on that porn still
yeah I mean it looks a little bit loose
for white here the King side but the
bishop on g2 is doing a very good job
and there is really nothing terrible
happening yeah Queen there on g3 is also
good and counter plane 37 is attacked
the rook on a6 is a little bit loose
yeah yeah this forces the Queen trade
yeah here they agreed to a draw we have
got equal material and no particular
weaknesses on either side that would
promise something to play for so draw
between the two tournament leaders yes I
think a slight disappointment maybe for
a wrong and whether I could have gotten
a very nice position out of the opening
with Bishop to f6 but it's an
opportunity that I thought he did not
that he did not take very important in
this is this event you have to yeah grab
those opportunities if he would have won
that game I would have made I think a
huge impact on the on the tournament but
as it as it was it was a draw again well
defended by
coyoacán the next game I want to look at
is wiggler Caruana sweet Lackawanna um
yeah the a game between two players who
need a win at some point
suela is on -1 after having lost 2 to
Ireland and karana has drawn all of his
games however his games were not
exciting than then Geary's six draws
karana for example was completely
winning against Apollo but couldn't
convert and there were some other
adventures in his games
okay we get an English opening against
villas really going with c4 in this
event five all symmetrical and now a g3
yeah here white has two main options you
can go g3 and deform g3 is some putting
a higher priority on the development of
the kingside deform is a bit sharper
because it gives black after the opening
of the center a little bit more options
after g3 - basically saying okay after
g6 I'm going to play d4 when I know that
you're feeling kiddo
what black has the option of doing
something entirely different
this is what he goes for in the game
karana plays d5 himself in Amman
officious way of playing but also very
well-respected takes takes Bishop g2
yeah in this position black has two main
moves he has g6 it's played in the game
or he has to move Knight to c7 I'm
actually slightly surprised that Kawana
when g6 it's not bad at all no not at
all but I think that 97 is something
that he has played in in in earlier
events and also successfully the typical
idea is to set up a new Roxy right here
with colors reversed and this is
something that's also quite ambitious
I mean without being overly risky so it
would have perfectly fit his tournament
situation to try to get to a somewhat
interesting game also with black note
that this uninteresting with 9075 is
more principled maybe okay g6 and
sevilla has something in store against
that Knight g5 interesting here just a
Texas
a Texas knight on d5 yeah what is black
supposed to do he does not really want
to move the night away yeah something
like let's say night to be six it's not
really helping that much the night is
not well positioned here and after
something like d3 and the later Bishop
III yeah like this this could become
vulnerable also after 94 and do you want
to go to c7 it's almost the same story
his six was played but that move we can
see dark squares quite a bit d3 Bishop
to g7 and IG to e4 very interesting the
night they're going why a g5 to e4 yeah
black um has to think about that c5 pawn
later but not right now as there's so
much pressure on c3 so he can cast off
first he doesn't have to play b6 or
anything like that yeah and now we come
to spill his idea he goes with h4 and
this makes an awful lot of sense in this
position White has not canceled yet the
f4 h4 um is supported by the rook and
black has moved its night away from the
king side so there is no knight on f6
that could naturally defend against the
h4 h5 push not a very nice position for
black to defend now not that he's in big
issue and big issues in big trouble
it shouldn't be like that next play was
completely logical up to that point but
still getting attacked like that is no
fun it's actually not clear what the
best defense is
you could argue that h5 is the
principled way to just put an end to
this but don't underestimate White's
chances here he has a couple of
interesting ideas
he can play Bishop to g5 as a more
conservative move attacking the Queen
and essentially provoking the move f6 or
provoking a queen move and what exactly
is your queen move in this position if
you go I know to be six something like
Queen d2 later Bishop h6 looks rather
comfortable also this could be an option
just winning this pawn or f6 but it's
that looking very attractive to you and
then also not right and white has even
more yeah more aggressive ways he can
try this move g4 I mean it looks very
very caveman style but don't
underestimate this this is getting
dangerous yeah I mean if black takes for
example rook takes it's a very early
opening of the king and why does not
take him long to get castle of long
maybe I know it looks very wacky but it
is not completely out of the picture
karana went with b6 and it seems that
the ensuing attack is really dangerous
what what else h6f was an idea but it's
not quite clear if it helps even the
computer and i mean i know that modern
engines are not as materialistic as they
were some some time ago but even the
computer like stockfish just wants to
give the exchange yeah this is stock
Fischer's main line and it gives white a
full compensation here for the exchange
which is not so surprising yeah why
has the bishop pair very nice active
bishops on D - G - the knight is strong
here can sometimes go back and blacks
king position is severely weakened here
on the dark squares definitely
compensation it's tougher black is
really tough not quite sure what blacks
best setup was he went b6 as mentioned
and now h5 that was the point
Bishop d7 no ticks and pawn takes yeah
in the press conference wiggler said
that F takes was maybe better a move
that looks extremely ugly because of
that situation of the Nydia the knight
is such such a nice piece on your form
but it seems that this setup at least
wasn't as dangerous for the black king
in the game after Bishop h6 it seems
that black is already in some trouble I
mean at least it gets very very tough in
the game Knight takes c3 was played let
us have a look at black captures this
was an alternative rook takes and maybe
King to g7 yeah the problem is the rook
does not have to retreat there is Queen
to d2 and after possible Luke h8 rook
takes Queen takes long castles rook h1
will be decisive so really really bad
for black this simple approach does not
work so what is blacks supposed to do he
tried the move Knight takes c3 but that
also doesn't solve his problems there
are a couple of trials that the engine
tries to make work but it ultimately is
always dangerous this is what the
computer also wants to try but Queen d2
and long castles is very simple to play
and all
this what the computer wants to do is
probably not ultimately satisfactory not
sure where the book wants to go or
squares make some sense you know white
also has a g4 as an opportunity
yeah I think white always retains some
pressure yeah this has happened in the
game taking and now the move f5 and
after that white probably has a very
very big advantage and I said difficult
to give him a device it's it's just a
very dangerous position
Quincy one novice Villa he just lets
this night
hang on e4 but he crashes through on the
edge farm takes check check King to f6
and now D takes e4 that was very very
strong play yeah white is a piece down
but his attack is very very strong he
has a couple of ideas the main idea at
the moment is to move e5 opening up the
diagonal and harassing the black king
Khurana now played route to h8 which is
probably the best defense 95 check and
King to f7 we have to give Khurana
credit now for the game from here he got
into trouble out of that opening
probably also against something that
swindler has prepared at home but now
Cohanim plays absolutely perfect defense
I think he is almost all the time
hitting the precise computer move here
okay Queen takes is not a big deal to
see I mean this is gently or not
calculating not the way so Queen takes
and now please long castles and wow this
is so dangerous yeah rook t7 check
coming what is
Black's move now yeah this is what he
tried and it's good
again it's a good defense Luke f8 was an
alternative um here in the press
conference wiggler showed a cute line
Queen to g5 Luke f7o cage one look at
five I know honey
Queen to f6 to decide decide the issue J
yeah and white will win this ending very
comfortably with an exchange of yeah
this box koalas choice doesn't look
pretty but it is a tougher defense
Andrew conveyed rook d7 look at eight
queen g4 yeah Kuji fourth also right
Queen g5 is not as convincing as Queen
h5 is holding on Queen g4s banner it
just it also looks and in both pawns
here yeah Queen h6 check check only move
f4 and now black has no ways defending
the piece I mean you cannot defend a
piece anymore
the bishop is attacked if you move it
away yeah white is just taking here and
here what is there yeah maybe this move
can check this but here probably rook
takes the 8s winning the house Luke
takes check check b7 black has no
counter check cm and we lose against the
e pawn I guess this is also just winning
from a material point of view almost
yeah rook e8 not beautiful but it's the
move that defense in the most stubborn
way this is what Khurana needs to do
here note that he's fighting for his
life in the event if he's losing the
game he's almost out of it him - one
squad after seven rounds
is not going to cut it rook takes busy
bee 795 the still trick is not possible
Queen f3 takes takes bishop here okay
seven so we got this ending so karana
avoided getting checkmated that was the
number one priority and there was such a
strong attack you could easily get
checkmated
but his precise defense has prevented
that he has escaped after that into the
ending that is probably lost against
perfect play but you still have to put
up that perfect play let's look what
happened in the next couple of moves
like what activated his Bishop they are
nicely trade see em check and basically
the computer agrees with with but I mean
with both sides play up to this point
after if for please white still retains
a big advantage but the engine points
out that group to b7 it's stronger the
problem is with this move is playing
this move just a couple of moves before
the time control is that black has a
very clear counter play with the Jeep on
this is what Sweden probably couldn't s
couldn't assess correctly and a group
takes g4 and this is getting somewhat
dangerous this pawn especially if you're
looking at look at the most normal moves
after a four
King g7 the black is covering this and
now the Jeep one gets very dangerous the
computer have a points out that III is a
strong move this is difficult to see
Jack Chick now
and after kingi to here white has
excellent winning chances the problem is
not so much to see a move like III once
it is on the board but to judge route b7
correctly yeah you have a hard time to
judge those little precise nuances when
you have no time and he was down to very
little time before whatever as I said it
does not spoil the game I mean white
still retains the big advantage but who
p7 it seems was stronger he 5j check
here the king C form going forward could
also go to see to it this is not a bad
move 94 Bishop to c6 and rook takes c3
yeah so white activated himself to dare
to the utmost yeah rookie three had to
be played covering that night and now
King b6 yeah in this particular moment
probably um karana had to play Knight to
c3 and this is getting him very close to
a draw after king c5 gently v King
before there is the move rook to h5 that
covers the bishop check by technical
means very difficult point spot so that
was the cleanest oops
Knight c3 was probably the cleanest
option but he went C find after that
again
what can probably win now with a four he
played this move but a for probably wins
it's tough it's really tough but it
should win there for example check here
check came to a5 or King to c7 kc7
probably no c3 is not also mainly back
and then the a porn can start to go ic3
however probably not the most precise
move ye should be 5 is still c3 or King
to d7 is also an option
after that rook c7 to probably stop the
porn it's still complicated it's very
complicated but what's clear after
Bishop d5 what's with the plate um the
King h8 now he was down to very little
but he could try the relatively best now
was probably to take on c4 now and even
here after this bishop moves who takes a
four he can try at least a little bit
because the bishop is a lot stronger
than the night the likelihood of a draw
is very high of course now yeah this is
what he did he 6 + c3 in ruku c7 g5 and
now he decided to end the game by taking
on e4 so very disappointing result for
Peter Svidler who had a very good
preparation a very good idea in the
opening and got a fantastic position but
it's really important to understand how
well Khurana defended this he probably
yeah would was lost and more than one
point but he always kept it going and
never really totally yeah broke down
from the pressure I think I think for
example if I would have that position
yeah after I have to move let's say move
19 or something like that I would I
would be checkmated I'm totally sure I
would fall to some some aid or some
direct loss which he did not which did
not happen to him he just continued to
fight on it was losing yes
against perfect flavored it's difficult
to do so at the end a draw very
disappointing for swindler and it keeps
Kawana in content
this event okay let's look at Nakamura
to power off the game between the two
tail and us they both are on are they
both no now come to eyes on - - - part
of us on - three no - two as well I'm
sorry yeah I'm getting confused them
anyway
both are almost out of it I mean if you
want to if you are super optimistic
person you can say okay if this game has
a winner the winner still has some some
options if they can continue with
another win to get back to 50% so this
it's not a game where draw is a serious
option okay got a sloth and this line
yet the part was still very much
intended seems of playing very solid
openings here with black I know okay
they he tried this this age for against
giri in the room before but he is back
again with very solid black opening here
in this law Bishop f5 yeah this is the
old main line is there nowadays a6 has
seen quite often that Bishop f5 of
course is happened quite or happening
quite all 93 egos is 6 again a 6 is the
fashion nowadays one point of this move
of this a six movies that after ecigs
white comes Knight h4 and after a six
the move Knight h4 it's not as some yeah
it's not as pointed as black has
additional options for example he can't
play to e6
which he could not do before I'm not
saying that this is brilliant but he
gets additional ideas there you six are
ever played by to par love night h4 and
Bishop g6 this is again the most solid
move and this is a bit sharper provoking
the move f3 yeah what often goes a3
Bishop g6 back and from here there are
many options Queen b3 96 immediately
okay this was played takes takes rook p1
yeah Luke p1 it's interesting and that
camera plays an idea that was introduced
by his opponent but to part of in the
2006 World Championship match the part
of chrome nikitha the toilet gate match
Andrew p1 is an interesting move it
tries to prepare a setup that you could
call and yeah a big a big expansion set
up what wide wants to do is he wants to
play a c5 b4 b5 maybe f4 yeah just push
all these pawns and trying to crush
black by pure space advantage Knight bTW
cell by the power of n c5 that is the
point root p1 is needed so that after a
move like b6 wasn't played here but
after that before as possible and white
is ready to support him with before
after a 5 years a 3 to Parliament in a5
a3 and now Bishop e7 just developing
normally
yeah g3 now played by nakamura this is
doing two things that prepares them a
fianchetto but it also stabilizes the
King side a little bit and it's simple
some cases prepares to move f4 f4 is
also a move here but after b6 this is
probably a little bit earlier black also
has an idea to play this yeah with this
idea or Bishop H for me this is also why
do you three make some sense it prepares
a just like f4
yeah II five now by 2 Paulo expanding in
the center Bishop g2 and now II for ya
gaining space is a sharp move he also
could have taken on D form
and played this position however it's
certainly not bad for white to have that
bishop out in the open so I understand
why a phone was played at least it makes
the bishop one c1 look a little bit
stupid before nine of eight that Knight
gets the regrouping and b5 and note that
white is not canceling 96 Bishop d2 yeah
white is still not cancelling yeah if he
would have done so he was probably
afraid that some Knight g5 27m is coming
there is no need yet to cancel so I
understand why he didn't okay Bishop d2
and now black cancelled now very
ambitious played by nakamura Knight to
a4 the other night intends to go to b6
and also make some way in some cases for
the rook to come to the six yeah 95 this
is very provocative play now by T'Pol
off he basically says okay you know I go
to g5 and if you play H form I'm going
to sacrifice that pawn on f3 or at least
yeah I'm going to play Knight f3 and um
make make a whole mess of this position
and this is what happened h4 9 and 3
check so ok
White has to take it no question there
and now we see the first point of this
the White Queen cannot capture the pawn
because the knight on a 4 is quite
clearly offside so what to do the most
obvious thing to do is what Nakamura did
he took on c6 and went back to c3
basically saying okay that's own eyes
what you did but I'm going to get that
part what is your big point and now we
see to par love some
and I think this is really an absolutely
fantastic decision he sometimes yeah how
do you call he sometimes plays a little
bit too dynamically to part of this and
it it blows up in his face but there are
moments in the games wave really finds a
solution that I really believe that
almost no player would would come up
with and this is one of those black now
played for me absolutely shocking move
Bishop takes e5 takes on c5 sacrificing
a bishop yeah what is the point there I
mean this is really interesting
of course why it takes the takes the
piece I mean you can I mean if you are
maybe the most boring player ever you
can think oh I'm scared I'll take this
but well now Nakamura needs to win the
game so he takes the takes a piece and
it is not clear-cut at all but I think
the idea here but Apollo is really
fantastic that he spotted that he has
compensation here for his piece you can
argue if it is absolutely full
compensation but the practical chances
are exceptionally well exceptionally
good okay deform that was the point now
attacking the knight on c3 White has no
alternative now he has to take that take
that pawn the knight has no good squares
anywhere something like night a 4d Forza
because this is a complete disaster and
things like that that's not going to
work so what has to take on deform yeah
he actually has a choice I think he
probably played it right by taking on d4
with the Queen even though rook e8 was
also interesting an interesting move
yeah just checking yeah King f1 is not
great after 24 especially route d8 is an
is an awful poon threat now
it's it's quite funny the computer gives
now as the mainline Bishop to e1 and now
this is the computer's answer here just
playing a root down but the situation is
for white is really really awkward
yeah Quincy one there is no other
squares that cover cover the night and
then Knight to g4 rook b2 is at the end
of Plex play no that's nice right
rook chicks has to be played check check
and I know it looks funny but this is
ending in a draw
yeah black can't try all kinds of things
here but it will end in a draw white can
dot dodge all those bullets and
ultimately it will be a perpetual check
very very funny line but new p8 Bishop
e3 is probably stronger and after rook
a3 b3 this is probably not quite enough
I mean black here again has some play
but 91 seems to consolidate for white
it's not totally clear cut again but in
comparison I think to Paulo's choice in
the game BAP just taking on d4 is
probably better ok castles and this is
the thing he gave up the piece to part
of did for just a pawn and he did for
see obviously that even after Wyatt
castling and white managed to cancel now
he has a very serious compensation and
one point is of course this move black
who wants to be ready to deliver that
checkmate so the white queen is
basically tied to to that f3 pawn he
always the the Queen always has to be
ready to take on f3 and cares of black
playing Queen h3 and
this makes a whole wide set up somewhat
awkward rookie want attending would be
three years a good move Luke 2:8 and
rugby - there are no big alternatives
there white has to cover that D - bishop
and rook t form activating the rook
potentially doubling but also sometimes
using the rook on the fourth-ranked
rupees seven active play by Nakamura
then more obvious move is probably rook
to e3 but it's ultimately probably not
leading to that much after rook T 891
this is the line that that stop fish
gives we get to a salute ending where
white wins that pond but very likely the
blank is active enough to hold the draw
yeah this is something you can analyze
deeper if you if you like but I don't
know how relevant it is to the game this
is already on with six or seven from the
game position and it's very tough to
decide on that and I mean White has a
white can't keep the piece for the
moment and why not do that Ruby 7 is an
interesting move in intending Queen to
b3 yeah rook th doublet Queen b3 and now
very cool flavor to power he just goes
rook j f8 yeah going to that passive
looking square but okay f7 was hanging
and it seems that it's not a big problem
for black because after whitest yeah
gain that short momentum with the
threaten of 7 he now has to think again
about this idea so Queen d1 has to be
played
White has to go back to help in the
defense he's really cool I think that
black has compensation in the form of
this active pieces so fantastic judgment
by the
Paul off with his capture on c5 really
I'm totally amazed by that concept that
he judged that correctly it really seems
that it's a kind of very dynamic
equilibrium that we that we have him
okay what happens Queen to b3 again you
have a repetition but now ninety one was
played by nakamura he definitely does
not want to draw here and now now we
come to a critical moments of the game
this was played by the parlor very
logical looking move it attacks the rook
on e7 it closes that diagonal it looks
at the e3 square probably still not the
best movement seems that tweener five
the computer suggestion was a very
decent alternative
the idea is to yes still have that Queen
yeah active there and sometimes have
also groups
I almost only have painted have the
knight dancer of d5 rookie aid is also
an idea
once the Knight has moved yeah this is
what the computer gives here look III
look to the eight rook a three queen c5
and black will get a piece back and he's
I mean at least equal here me he played
this so I mean it's very difficult is
this kind of situation look five and
here to Paulo is down to probably just
one one move that he has to play and
this is probably Luke a8 this is what
the engine gives after you let it
calculate for for quite a while it's
quite interesting to to check that move
rook eight what is White's reply now the
point is that in in some cases
like is able to take on the - for
example after this this is going to save
black
yeah the captures net mate
and this is the threat after king g1
yeah there's a chick and again this is
going to be a draw the problem is that
white oops
here cannot stop this and this at the
same time now the night has no good
square I also note that check this check
should be forgotten in the game to pile
of the plate King to h7 again under
under time pressure and the problem is
that now after King edge to the move
Knight f4 it's not leading anywhere or
let's say this I mean this kind of move
is not leading anywhere because after
King G 192 now this is stopped so what
what exactly is black supposed to do
after King edge - a problem is there is
nothing anymore yeah that move was just
not not right and here Nakamura yeah had
managed to defend this successfully you
have any any other ideas for black what
he tried is this Knight to f6 but what
else is there one issue is quite
importantly importantly a quite
important issue is that after f6 93 is a
good reply attacking the Queen and after
Knight takes rook takes this is going to
fall yeah a bit of a tragic end to that
game I think - follows play was really
am really really strong very interesting
play but this is
the problem sometimes with such an
ambitious and enterprising approach to
the game if you are not in in 100% top
shape it can happen that you get into
those those yeah do-or-die positions
make one mistake and then you lose and
this is what happens to him in that
event yeah quite a bit he he kind of he
steers up the complications and then
does not find in the very critical
moments find the best moves that keep
him in the game or even wins him the
game as he yeah could have done it round
one
winning is that I I guess he was close
to winning against Arnold if he plays
the right continuation so what about
this round what is the the main result
let's say of the round this wind brings
that camera back into yeah at least
glimmers of hope
yeah - to was completely disastrous -
one at least you can imagine that
something could happen well to pile of
us now on - three and really get us out
of it
yeah it was very difficult before me
anyway now it's there's no chance
whatsoever
another key game was Sevilla not being
able to beat Caruana which means kiwanis
so is still in the in the hunt and
sweida
where this - one score it's not looking
too great you hope you enjoyed the
coverage of round six round seven
coverage will also beyond shortly thanks
for watching